hello and welcome to the new world
review source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back
balls deep within hunter hunter to put
together another fancy and likely
controversial list
aiming to rank the top 20 best known
abilities within the series
controversial because you know nen is a
very trixie power system that is
designed to meet a wide variety of needs
and even though hunter hunter
is admittedly as shown in series this
means that the most powerful or the
strongest abilities
are not necessarily the best however
what i can say is that one of the
objectively best abilities
is your power to subscribe to the new
world review which will result in
regular injections of hunter hunter
administered into your youtube feed very
important you stay on top of your weekly
inoculations there but we will now go
through the methodology for this beast
of a list and if you want to skip to the
rankings then you can do
so by going to this time but i would
highly encourage you to stay because
none abilities are complicated as is the
english language and
understanding how i define the term best
is going to be pretty integral but if
you truly have no interest in such a
thing then please do stay regardless and
for your viewing and pleasure we will
have a slideshow of hunt hunter ladies
playing in the lower corner here to
maintain your
attention whilst the adults talk to
begin though this is going to be quite
similar to how we found our best and
worst nine users every ability was
ranked according to four separate
categories
and awarded a score out of 25 in each
all of which add together to form a
mighty number out of 100 which ended up
giving us the abilities final score now
the first of these four categories is
suitability this is designed to measure
how well inendability meets the needs of
its user and it exist because hatsu are
so
intrinsically linked to their users that
we cannot ignore this connection and an
example of a character who would receive
a high score in this area would be
krapika who basically crafted himself a
swiss army knife of abilities to meet
his very specific needs meanwhile a
character who would do
quite poorly is obviously chito whose
abilities tend to hinder or even
neutralize his own natural advantages
but next up we have versatility and this
section ranks abilities by how well they
can be applied in a wide variety of
situations because honestly speaking
hatsu with multiple uses will inevitably
perform much better in general than
those with very precise niche
applications then for our third category
we find efficiency and this factor is
intended to measure how well the ability
performs in exchange for its aura cost
or any restrictions and limitations
applied to illustrate hisoka's bungee
gum would be a very efficient ability
with high output for low or cost
meanwhile something like crolo skill
hunter is painfully inefficient due to
the complex and numerous restrictions
required to invoke it and finally we
have creativity and this feature is all
about how nin users think outside the
box to come up with unique and
intriguing abilities so something like
gonz dujanken probably wouldn't do
particularly well here due to its
simplistic and highly predictable nature
and on top of that there are also some
extras to concern ourselves with here
one important thing is that abilities
that are part of a set are considered as
one candidate such as guns to drunken
series because sure yes they are
technically three separate abilities but
they come under the same general
umbrella and something else to watch out
for is that characters who do have
multiple hatsu which are not part of a
set do have an
opportunity to appear multiple times on
this list which is going to be good fun
but without further ado let's begin this
exploration of the best-known abilities
in hunt hunter with our 20th place
contender rapidly evolving gungi skills
a funky little ability possessed by
funky little komiki and this is actually
one of the most wild entries right off
the bat because it actually has a
perfect score in three out of our four
categories in terms of suitability
efficiency and creativity this noun
ability is almost
unrivalled in the entire series
considering komagi's severe lack of aura
this thing is an absolute gem that
allows her to surpass the mental
capacities of
even the ant king merowem however the
big problem being that it can only be
used within the game of gungi hence it's
incredibly incredibly low versatility
score because there is no
versatility in fact i'll reveal right
here and now that this is by far the
lowest scoring then ability for this
category out of the almost 200 that were
analyzed still
absurdly perfect scores in every other
area means that rapidly evolving gunky
skills will make its claim
in the top 20. and moving on in number
19 we will find komagi's opponent's
meruem or more specifically marowan's
only original inability or a synthesis
basically a method of absorbing the
hearts of others but it does involve
quite literally absorbing parts of the
original user which is why the
efficiency score is well it's not quite
as perfect as it could be the highest
score here would be suitability though
because it's quite perfect for a king to
be able to make use of the trades of his
subjects
although it does lose a couple of points
simply due to the fact that if marouane
really wanted to he could undoubtedly
just create those abilities himself so
the whole aura synthesis thing
is a bit of an extra step i mean meruem
is a specialist with nylon infinite
quantities of aurora so
it is a tiny bit redundant but stepping
ahead into 18th place we find
needle people a rather terrifying set of
abilities possessed by illimizoldic and
i want to clarify that corpse control
hypnotic spell and needle people all
come under this banner because they're
essentially illumi doing the same thing
programming needles with aura but to
achieve different degrees of results
still we receive very solid scores in
three areas although the one thing that
does suffer a bit is the realm of
creativity and this is largely due to
the innate uncreativity of manipulation
needle people and its needle people
friends are all quite basic invocations
of this affinity and we have seen
countless other manipulators in the
series perform abilities very very
similar to this
with that said the needle people series
is slightly more expansive and slightly
more nuanced so that's definitely why it
does rank quite highly compared to many
of the other raw manipulation hearts
for now though it's time to head into
number 17 where we discover a delightful
texture surprise an ability so perfectly
suited to hisoka being a sneaky combat
clown and one that is heavily underrated
in comparison to bungee [ __ ] in reality
however texture surprise is the true ace
of hisoka's nan arsenal giving him this
simple yet essential option of deception
and the only category in which it really
falters is versatility which you may
initially think is quite insane
considering that texture surprise can
mimic almost any substance in existence
but the key thing to remember is that it
is
at all times a pure facade it's only as
valuable of an ability as its user is
intelligent which is great for hisoka
but
uh maybe not so great in general but for
something that is just pretty wild in
sixteenth place may i interest you in
some magical
spa surfaces biscuits fatigue fighting
hatsu and another heavily underrated
ability in general because it changes
the very
nature of well life suitability and
efficiency are very hard to argue with
when this ability can almost entirely
remove the need to sleep and as for
creativity look the outcome isn't
horrendously original but the
implementation certainly is the whole
idea of needing to transmute aura into a
super special massage lotion and have it
applied only by an emitted or conjured
we don't know which masseuse but
regardless it sounds quite relaxing and
gives us enough steps and restrictions
to make this hatsu actually possible but
breaking into 14th place we have a
curiously cool hatsu known as contagion
wielded by one mirena product
probably many unfamiliar words there for
anime only watches but morena is a very
key character in current manga events
with this frankly insane ability that
allows her to infect up to 22 people
once infected these people are initiated
into a little game whereby if they
complete the condition set up by moreno
they level up and as they level up they
gain nen abilities of their own and upon
reaching level 100 they also gain the
ability to infect others and yes that is
a gross oversimplification
of the ability for the sake of time here
but if you are familiar with moreno
suitability is not even a question but
versatility is also amazing because it's
one of the only nun abilities capable of
creating
new nun abilities it's stupidly
efficient and the whole game framework
is very creative but something much
simpler now let's take a look at machi's
nan threads in 14th place
a very basic and not quite original idea
but a formidable force in every category
regardless as a member of the phantom
troupe machi's threads serve her
phenomenally allowing for top offensive
capabilities healing properties and even
puppeteering manipulation that could
probably put shell knock to shame hence
why the threads are also wonderfully
versatile and efficient
and look i just i have little to no
complaints with nen threads other than
maybe
they could have a more creative name
come on we can do better it's about as
creative as number 13 which is going to
be dragon head
wielded by xenozoldic and very
predictably they see xeno transmute
hizora into the form of a dragon head as
well as the rest of the dragon body
sometimes which very excitingly can be
used as transportation instantly
skyrocketing that area of versatility
but in addition to that dragon head is
also part of a set which includes the
option of drag and dive all of which is
very creative and efficient suitability
is
maybe a bit low for this list though and
that's simply because all of these very
big and loud options perhaps are not the
best for a professional assassin but at
the same time i suppose that very much
depends on the job doesn't it perhaps
not every assassination need be a
stealthy affair
looking under the microscope now though
we find an ant in twelfth place
many many ants actually an infestation
if you will
resulting from shampoos beelzebub hatsu
one of the highest efficiency scores on
this list actually because the results
of splitting oneself into nanosegments
far outweighs the aura cost and the fact
that there seem to be pretty much no
restrictions on this ability
is something that does perpetually
boggle my mind a high versatility score
is also achieved here because having
thousands of mini-me sounds
sounds quite productive doesn't it but
it doesn't achieve a perfect score
because of the size restrictions that
will inevitably affect said versatility
all in all though an incredibly solid
ability and certainly one of the best
that we've seen in hunter hunter but
sticking with the ant theme in 11th
place we find
rage incarnate a very last minute
discovery from men to the uppity but it
achieves an immediate full score on
suitability because an
angry ant being able to channel their
angry ant rage into pure aura resulted
in an already insurmountable up
transcending
into an almost deity like level of nenus
which also leads to fantastic scores and
versatility and efficiency because when
inability is designed to simply just
generate or for you that's pretty much a
dream in this world granting you far
more options for the very agreeable
price of
nothing at all i mean there is something
you do have to get angry like
very angry so maybe this is not a great
ability for some but for the more rage
consumed among us this
is quite an unparalleled hatsu moving
along now though number 10 is also not
to be underestimated as we embark on a
game of hide and seek with not and of
every none ability in the series i would
strongly consider choosing this one to
be my personal hatsu there is just
something so
especially overpowered in the idea of
creating pocket dimensions which
entirely revolutionize your life in
terms of storage and transportation
i know two very boring sounding words
but you'll appreciate them a hell of a
lot more when you achieve god mode in
them and other than
maybe magical spa services hide and seek
is probably the most useful non-ability
that you could give just an everyday
general person it's not specific it
doesn't seem to have any crippling
restrictions and it grants phenomenal
power and as for more and more power a
9th place finisher delivers us some
crazy slots very appropriate because
there are 9 slots as part of this
ability
but even though crazy salt appears to be
a purely combative hatsu the sheer range
of weaponry and impressive slew of
limitations makes this ability
undeniably versatile and efficient in
fact it even has a perfect score and
efficiency in particular because it is
one of the most impressively efficient
uses of nen that we've ever seen through
the stupid yet
highly achievable layers of restrictions
highly creative as well and it's hard to
complain about suitability given that
these nine slots can apparently offer
kite anything he needs at any given
moment but in number eight now we have a
bit of a surprise i suspect because here
we encounter the battle cantabile series
from bononov which i will remind you
consists of his conjured armor the
utility of spawning a miniature jupiter
to destroy anything and everything as
well as this mysterious third kantabu
function which allows bernoullinov to
metamorphosize into a wide variety of
things the suitability and versatility
is pretty shockingly great as is
efficiency because if the only true
restriction on the ability is playing
music and yes granted this is not an
ability that can be given to any human
it is much
much more personalized than most of that
regard but if that's the only thing
holding it back and we are looking at a
pretty serious contender here as is
seventh place which presents us with an
ability known as benjamin baton
possessed very predictably by a man
named benjamin one of the karkin princes
currently involved in the succession war
and for those of you who are not
familiar with the manga benjamin baton
doesn't actually do
anything on its own but it does allow
benjamin to inherit the non-abilities of
his subordinates should they pass away
and currently benjamin has inherited
three nen abilities which he is able to
use one of which funnily enough is the
ability to steal the abilities of others
thus making benjamin's current nine
potential kind of insanely endless but
for what it is it's painfully suitable
extraordinarily versatile within reason
also very efficient because you're just
recycling the powers of your dead army
and yeah it's just in general pretty
damn creative
good job benjamin baton however moving
into the realm of gods for a second in
sixth place we now gaze upon the 100
type guanine in bodhisattva a very
familiar ability that i'm sure is burned
into the minds and hearts of every hunt
hunter fan
and as such perfect scores are achieved
in suitability and creativity it's an
absolutely marvelous idea and this
ability can only really reside within
one person being network the versatility
isn't perfect because there are problems
with summoning the static statue and
having to re-summon it every time you
move as well as the fact that it is
highly combat oriented even if the hand
combinations themselves are essentially
infinite but where it stumbles a bit
more is efficiency because look if
you're not isaac netro with his
superhuman arm movement then this
ability is actually quite clunky and
slow to control
definitely not the worst but a pretty
large detriment nonetheless now next up
in the coveted
fifth place position we have a bit of a
tricky one being wish granting the
trademark ability of
nanika i say tricky because look it's
never really been confirmed that this is
the result of nen but hunter hunter
being what hunter hunter is you just
have to assume that everything revolves
around aura until proven otherwise even
bizarre dark continental gas creatures
and with that in mind it's very
difficult to argue versatility and
efficiency when this power can make
quite literally anything happen in fact
it kind of breaks the scale completely
but will settle for perfect scores for
now
suitability is also a tricky one because
it doesn't really assist nanika
personally and creativity is
well the ability certainly gets points
for the creative ways in which it pays
for its wishes brutal
as they may be stepping into fourth
place we have the one and the only
the bungee gum and of every ability in
hunt hunter i feel like this is the only
one that i
never need to explain because the
comment section will inevitably do that
for me but bungie gum
is almost boringly perfect its
suitability to hisoka is supreme we all
know how versatile it is and it's
incredibly efficient considering exactly
what it is and look all of the points in
the world minus four for creativity
because it really does take a childlike
imagination to really bring something
like this into existence as for
something that takes the mind of a very
vengeful adult the bronze medal of this
list is heading in karapika's general
direction
for emperor time this is an ability that
was designed to completely break the
rules of nan and
it worked quite brilliantly even if
there is you know a great deal of
confusion in the fanbase regarding how
it actually works
it is quite a costly power though which
is why the lowest score happens to be
efficiency i mean
i suppose it is quite efficient provided
that you don't plan on living for too
long but it is an essential item that
gives way to our second place contender
which is karapika's chainset that's
right we have a good old
one-two punch of cropica here but this
chainset presents us with almost
the most perfect use of men that one
could ever ask for the right tools for
the right job in regards to croppika the
versatility to apply them to any
unexpected situation the efficiency to
wield pizza abilities at a level that a
conjurer really should not have access
to and creativity
bam through the moon the only thing is
the chain said that really only does
work to most degrees with emperor time
also active but i really couldn't
justify binding them together because
they are two very different things which
i suppose leaves us only with number one
an ability that i'm sure
many many of you have predicted and it
is of course deep
purple i've probably spent enough time
hyping this up in every other video that
references moral but this
is far and away just plain the best
hatsu in the entire series primarily
because it can do pretty much
anything you want to at a stupidly
efficient cost and creativity is more or
less infinite although i will say that
the mechanics of how deep purple work
only emphasize these features
very efficient and very creative
thinking went into the construction
of this here bad boy i would never call
it the most powerful inability but at
the same time that's not really what we
were looking for here we were looking
for the best and deep purple
you have been crowned as the best but if
you'd like to examine some of the best
net news in the series then please do
check out this video which ranks the top
20 best men users in hunter hunter but
for now this has been the new world
review
and i'll see you next time